so in this final select video i'll cover
computing reachability probabilities for
mvp so this is both minimum and maximum
reachability
probabilities so there's several
different
approaches so i'll cover value iteration
which is a
a which is a approximate
slop method and um it is an iterative
solution method and it corresponds to a
fixed point computation as we'll see
and this is preferable in
practice for example as it's used in
slap prism
and i'll show you a second approach
which is a reduction to a linear sub
programming
sub problem and then we can solve with
linear optimization
techniques and this is has a better
our complexity although it's not better
in
practice and it's good for small slight
examples and
it also gives precise slight results as
opposed to value
iteration which is only gives so
approximate
answers and i'll also mention a third
step method which is policy iteration
so let's first consider value iteration
and let's consider when we're computing
minimum
slot probabilities so this can be it's
like computed as
the limit so here we're computing select
the probabilities for
all states at the same time so it's like
the probability
um the minimum probability for state s
it's like reaching t is slightly the
limit
of these over n so let's look at the
case for state s
what's the nth slight value
well it's um one if it's in just like
the target as we've already
as if we're in the target then so the
probability has to be except one either
from
both for minimum and maximum it's
it's like zero if we can't get there
with
it's like probability strictly greater
than
so zero and i show you how to compute
this
set in the previous video
and then if n is like equal to zero then
we start from
zero and if n is it's like greater than
zero
and we use then we so base it on
the values in some it's like other
states so we take
the minimum as we're computing a minimum
probability over the it's like available
actions and then we sum over all a
possible
successor states and we multiply it's
like the probability of moving to the
successor state given that we performed
except the action a
and then it's like we multiply that by
the previously it's like computed
probability for the successor state
so for s prime
so this is a approximate iterative
so solution a technique but as we can
see this
it's in these probabilities are
these so that are increasing and they
converge to
the minimum select probabilities for max
it's
almost the same obviously we now do a
max over the
available slot action and
so the only other change is here and
here it's those states
where the maximum probability of
reaching the target
is equal to zero
so we can view this as a fixed point
just like computation similar to as for
dtmcs so for example in it's like the
minimum case
we can consider it's like the amount the
function that goes from
probability so vectors to it's like
probability it's like vectors
where it returns one if the state is in
select the target
zero if
it's like the probability of the minimum
probability of getting to the target is
zero and so otherwise we do the same
thing as
so previously we take select the minimum
over all
actions and then it's like the
probability of moving to a success
state multiplied by the previous or
except that
the probability is that value in y
now if we let x zero uh if we let the
zero
set back to b um the vector
will select zeros and the n plus one
sub vector be given by this function
applied to the nth um slope vector
then we have that this is a we end up
with an
increasing sequence of these are point
wise increasing
sequence of slight vectors and they
converge to the minimum
probability of reaching just like the
target
and this is actually the unique fixed
point of this
slight select function and the case for
so maximum
is the same all that we change here is
that this changes to max
and we take a maximum over the available
actions so let's now
apply these techniques to an example so
let's consider this
mdp here so here we have a
we only have a choice in state um we
have a choice in state s
zero so there's this slight distribution
here
we go to s2 with probability of half s
s3 with
probability one quarter and s and we
stay in
zero with some probability one quarter
or
with probability point one we go to s
one while in
s3 we've got a non-deterministic choice
so between going to s2 with probability
one
or staying in s3 with probability one so
i've
omitted the action so labels just to
keep things
slightly simple so let's consider
um value iteration where we want to find
the minimum probability that we get to
s2 so our
target is um sm2 and what states
um is so the minimum probability of
getting to s2 equal to zero well that's
only s3 because in s3 we can just choose
to take this
self loop over and over again and then
we will never get
to s two so
let's let's have a look at this so we've
got s
min so greater than zero is s zero s one
and s two
and s three isn't in the state as so as
i've just said the probability of
the minimum probability of getting to t
is indeed it's like
it's like zero so let's have a look at
the probability it's like vectors that
we get so
in the zeroth case will s1 and
s0 and s1 are it's like it's like zero
as we this is the zeroth case s2 is one
because it's like the target and s3
is zero because it the minimum
probability is like 0. so then in
s 0 we take the minimum
over this choice here and this choice
here
while in s1 there's no such choice so we
just have this one
update here and this yields these slot
probabilities here
then if we apply it again then we get
these slight probabilities here
and if we keep going and then we'll see
that we
eventually converge to select the
probability
for m s 0 is
two thirds for s 1 it's 14
out of 15. obviously it's one for s2
is that it's like the target and
obviously it's zero for s3 as
the minimum probability as we've seen is
slight
slight zero so
we can then extract what the minimum
strategy is so if we see here we see
that it's
this our distribution here that
that yields select the value
to it's like it's like thirds so this
is like the optimal thing to take if we
want
slightly minimum probability and as
as i've said if we take this soft loop
then the minimum probability of reaching
the target s2 is like zero obviously if
we took
this one then we'd get there with it's
like probably the probability
it's like one so therefore
this this slight induces this our dtmc
which yields the these
select probability probabilities as
well so now let's go on to
the second approach which is based on
programming so here this is the
optimization of a linear
objective sub function subject to a
number of linear
inequalities and it's like equality
constraints and there's many standard
solution techniques for um such things
such as
the simplex ellipsoid select method and
the interior point
method to name just a few so in its
select general form we've got a number
of variables let's say we've got n
variables x1
up up to xn then so we want to maximize
or it's like minutes and it's like
minimize some
linear combination of these
slight variables so c1 up to cn are
like constants and so we want to
maximize or
minimize this sum and then we have a
number of
our constraints so we've got a number of
inequalities here and again the a's and
the b's
are just like it's like constants
and we can consider this in sort of it's
like matrix and
vector form in that we want to maximize
or
minimize c times x subject to
some matrix times x less than or equal
to
some constants b so let's see how
this works for um minimum reachability
probabilities so actually some minimum
reachability probabilities can be select
computed as follows so as
for value iteration we set set the
values
equal to one if we're in the target set
of such states is obviously then it's at
the reachability
so probability is one we're already
there and at zero
if um the minimum reachability
so probability is not greater than zero
and
we've already seen how to compute this
set of states now
for the remaining set of states so let's
call the set
set s question mark as we don't know set
the probability
yet then this can be obtained as the
unique solution of the following linear
programming
sub problem so here so we want to
maximize
the sum of the um
variables xs and it's subject to
the constraint xs is less than or equal
to the sum
so these are over all of the states in s
select question mark so that notice this
is over
all available actions
in in state s so
for any available action a it's the sum
over
s prime the probability that if we take
a we go to s prime then select
multiplied
by set the value for um s prime and then
we also
sum this is it's like
set the probability when we're in s that
we reach
the target in a single step
okay so that's for select minimum
and then all that changes for it's like
maximum
is instead of doing a
select maximize here and a less than
or so equal inequality here we get a
it's like minimize here and a greater
than or equal
to quality here and that's all that
changes there is one other change so
obviously in that we
here we have s max is like
greater than zero as opposed to s min
sub greater than zero
okay so let's see this in slight
practice
so let's first do a case of select min
so here um if it's
select minimum as we've seen here
s3 so first of all so this is at the
target so
here we set x2 to be it's like one s
sum three we can do this loop
and so here it's like the probability
the minimum
probability of getting to the target so
zero so we set x three to be
select zero and then we've got what
we're left with in s
so question mark is x zero and x one
so we want to maximize the the sum of x0
plus
x1 subject to the our constraints
so first for this choice here this is
x0 is less than or equal to x1 and then
for this choice um
here we end up with one
so this is x zero is less than or equal
to
one it's like quarter times x
it's like zero because we get back to s
it's like zero here
this is one quarter times
it's like zero so it isn't here and this
is one half times one
or one half and then for
x in in state s1 for x1
we get 1 10 times x
0 then plus 1 half times x
1 and then 2
fifths times one as we've reached it's
like
it's like the target now it we can
simplify this a bit so
we can take the x so zero here over to
set the other side and the x one here
over to set the other side
so we then get three quarters times x
zero and one half times
x one here and then
we can move the three quarters over to
the other side and the one half
over to the other side and we end up
with x zero
less than or equal to two thirds and x
one is less than or equal to
one fifth times x zero plus four
fifths so let's have a look at these
constraints so it's so the white area
that
satisfies the our constraint so these
so this is where x0 is less than or
equal to x1
this is where x0 is less than or equal
to two-thirds
and this is where x1 is less than or
equal to one-fifth times x0 plus
um four and fifths so we want to
maximize
the sum such that all of these are
satisfied so let's look at when all of
these are
it's like satisfied so that gives this
white area here
so all that i've done is i've just like
combined these
into one single slight graph and then
that leaves us with this white area here
and then it's like we want to maximize
the the sum
so we find that the maximum is here and
we get the
it's like it's like solution of two
thirds and
14 over so 15 corresponding to what we
found with value
iteration so we so we have the though
x0 is two thirds x1 is 14 over
so 15 and then we had x2 is 1 and x3 is
equal to it's like slight zero okay so
just to give you
a just to show that we do end up with
the same
slight answer this was like the answer
that we found through
um the set of
linear
start programming slight problem and in
red
it's like shown so the values that are
computed by the select value select
iteration
okay so finally let's go on to a case
for
select select max so now let's look at
the maximum
probability that we get to other target
so here so again we've got x2 it's like
one
now there aren't any states so this
should be
s sub max so select apologies for that
but there aren't any states for which so
the maximum
of getting to here
and is so both s1
sorry s0 s1 and s3 all have except
probability
greater than zero of it's like reaching
the target in
except the maximum case as now s3
s and s3 we can always take this
transition here
so for um s0 s1 and s3 we get these
slight equations here so these
um these
first these these three here
are similar to are the same as
it's like before but we've got that the
arrows are
the inequalities are set the other way
around and now x3 is not equal to zero
so we've also got this here and then for
state
s um s3 we've got the two
our choices here so here if we choose
it's like this one we've got
x3 it's like greater than or equal to
one
since we've reached set the target here
and this is a
self loop so this just says x3 is
greater than or
equal to x3 so if we rearrange these
then we can simplify it to get these
equations here so if we first just look
at
x0 and x1 so the first
slight equation here this corresponds to
this
it's like white area here here we want x
zero
greater than or so equal to one so none
of this
area is it's like included and this is
the final case here so this white area
here is where x1 is
greater than or equal to one-fifth times
x0 plus
four four-fifths
so if we look if we are combined then we
and we take
certain minimum then we find that
there's only one feasible
solution and that's when x0 and x1 is
equal to slope one
okay so we've got the values for x0 and
x1 so what about x2
and x3 well we fought
x2 so we know it's it's like 1 because
it's it's like the target state and then
we also know that x3 is
greater than or equal to one and it's a
probability so it's equal to
step one so
in um so this is um
the maximum memory less adversary so in
s
slot zero it chooses this step here
and in that s3 it chooses this step here
so this yields this our dtmc here
which also has in each state
so the probability of getting to s2 is
indeed
it's like it's like one okay i'll only
briefly go over how policy iteration
works
so this is so in value iteration
obviously
so we iterate over the probabilities or
select the values
while for policy it's the iteration
we iterate over the strategies or
adversaries or
policies so we start with a arbitrary
select memoryless adversary or slight
strategy
then we compute so the reachability so
probabilities for that
strategy and then we try to improve that
slight strategy in each state is there a
better
so action that yields a higher
probability of
getting to other target and if there is
then we change to that
so action and we keep doing that
until we can't improve the strategy any
more and this will
terminate because there's only a finite
number of memoryless
adversaries or strategies
okay so let's so just to mention for
more general
probabilistic set properties
for um for example one can compute the
minimum
and so the maximum probability of
formula is is true and how
this works is um we first need to
compute
so the problem into just slight maximum
sub probabilities however we can do this
by using the fact that the minimum
probability of satisfying some
ltl slack property psi
is equal to one minus the maximum
probability of satisfying the
select negation of [ __ ]
and then similarly to select dtmcs
we need to um let's let's generate a
deterministic ravine automata force
psi although not psy if we were
interested
in minimum probabilities then we
construct a
product mdp and then
we have to identify
what are called accepting end select
components
um in this select product
so a end our component here is a set of
states such that there is a strategy
under which one always
so it remains in the set
so that with
select probability one under that
strategy we stay in that
it's like set and we also don't require
that under that strategy every
every state in that set is so visited
so infinitely often with probability
one and then we can compute the maximum
probability of reaching these accepting
end components okay so it's just a quick
it's an outline of
it's like how it works but it's the
fundamental part
is that we need to be able to just like
compute
maximum reachability probabilities
okay so one last thing just to say about
the
our complexity of this so if we use
linear
select programming uh
then this can be solved in
polynomial time for example using the
ellipsoid
method and for the the select
qualitative part then this is
um linear in the state space
so we can introduce also
it's like reward set structures for it's
like mdps here
so here we can either have set record
this is similar to it's like dtmc so we
can have
the reward it's not accumulated in a
state or the reward
so accumulated when performing a certain
action in a
it's like a select state and then
we can compute the minimum and select
maximum
expected cumulative so rewards except
before
start reaching a target
and the solution method
are similar to that that i've just
started showing you for
so probabilistic it's like reachability
okay
so that completes this set of videos so
there's many other
areas to um are probabilistic
systems and i just thought i would focus
on two of the
fundamental it's select models so that
is
it's got dtmcs and mdps and on
the fundamental properties of
probabilistic
and expected reachability
okay so thank you